[Musique]
une session de formation à l'école pop
school étaient organisées pendant dix
jours à elancourt nommé spring campaient
elle avait pour but de permettre à des
personnes en insertion professionnelle
de s'initier à six métiers du numérique
il s'appelle laura georges le nouveau
terrain synthétique de belfort désormais
le nom de l'ancien footballeuses du
paris saint germain l'occasion pour la
ville de promouvoir les figures
féminines sportive et enfin pour
refermer ce journal une rencontre maman
moynier et chevrières éducatrice
spécialisée elle a tout quitté depuis
deux ans et s'est installé sur
l'exploitation céréalière de ses parents
elle produit des glaces et bientôt des
fromages
[Musique]
à l'école pop school d'elancourt
s'achever ce vendredi une formation
sprint quand de dix jours cette session
a permis à des personnes en insertion
professionnelle de s'initier à six
métiers du numérique tels que web
designers ou encore développeur internet
avec une montée en puissance d'abord
trois métiers par jour puis ils en
choisissent trois qui vont découvrir sur
le reste de la semaine de façon un peu
plus poussée en fait beaucoup par du
partage d'expériences de professionnels
puis en fait pendant une semaine ils
vont réellement pratiqués en fait didier
a quant à lui découvert un logiciel de
community management dans le but de
s'orienter vers la communication
institutionnelle et j'ai été aidé parce
que je suis débutant et mais ça se passe
bien les gens sont sympathiques et
accueillants l'ambiance est bonne
intégré au sein du programme ensemble à
100% cette session de formation a permis
aux vingt-sept bénéficiaires parfois
éloignées de l'emploi de retrouver
confiance en eux on se fixe pas comme
ambition forcément que ces gens
s'orientent vers le numérique mais on
utilise plutôt le numérique comme un
levier pour prendre confiance en soi
pour oser pour faire faire cherche
soi-même pour sortir des sentiers battus
on a pris des jacquots des grâces aux
dévoués on a pris pas à modifier
certaines choses
sur des sites internet
comment les manipuler aussi là c'est le
site internet que j'ai créée c'est le
site d'un institut de beauté
c'est le projet qu'on va devoir
présenter vendredi
notre truc chez pop school c'est qu'il
ya pas de prérequis académique vous
pouvez venir sans le bac si vous êtes
motivé et si vous faites preuve d'une
appétence pour les sujets numériques on
va volontiers vous intégrer au même clip
qu'une personne qui a un bac + 3 ou bac
+ 4 dans une même promo les élèves ont
ensuite la possibilité d'intégrer un
simulateur d'entreprise pour une durée
de deux mois afin de réaliser des
projets plus ambitieux comme de vrais
professionnels
[Musique]
laura georges honoré à ben l'ancienne
joueuse de football féminin au paris
saint germain de 2013 à 2017 et est
présente sur le nouveau terrain de ben
portant son nom la footballeuse ne
cachait pas sa fierté j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi j'ai été étonné j'étais
surprise ah et puis après réflexion
après avoir échangé avec le président du
district que je connais du district des
civils bien j'ai accepté c'est un bel
honneur c'est une belle reconnaissance
pour moi et les membres de ma famille
c'est pas le seul stade qui porte son
fils mineur il y en a d'autres
le là où ça fait du sens et que ses deux
longues laura georges qui a fait
énormément pour le football féminin pour
cette pratique pour ces disciplines
désirant jouer sur place toute l'année
le fcb n attendait depuis 20 ans
l'arrivée de cette structure lui 150000
euros environ auront été nécessaires
pour créer ce terrain en fibre
synthétique de dernière génération mais
problème de l'eau terrain c'est que en
hiver une sont pas praticables et que
les clubs des clubs de foot évidemment
sont obligés d'émigrer dans d'autres
communes donc on a décidé de ball trap
au recul c'était dans notre programme
lire et longtemps fourniront là on s'est
dit il faut absolument qu'on trouve une
solution et terrasse est étiqueté comme
la meilleure solution la qualité du
terrain a été approuvé par l'ancienne
joueuse internationale c'est un beau
terrain de de qualité donc je suis
contente que les filles du club mais
également les jeunes puissent avoir un
terrain de qualité pour s'entraîner et
puis également pour jouer les week-ends
les personnes présentes sur place espère
que ce nouveau sol synthétique apportera
de nombreux succès au club du vin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
première édition de la fête de la
jeunesse à poissy l'occasion pour la
ville de célébrer de jeunes talents et
de faire découvrir de nouveaux sports
tels que le technopôle ou encore le bmx
flatland la particularité c'est de faire
des figures sur un sol plat
le but ne peut pas poser le pied par
terre et être le plus créatif possible
voilà le plus important c'est d'être
original et inventer ses propres figures
c'était un bon moyen de faire une petite
démo une petite initiation aussi pour
les jeunes de la ville surtout qu'à un
gros skate parc à côté on connaît très
bien ce sport j'en connais moins bien
que timo le milieu du e street rider du
bmx et c'est vrai qu'une vision du vélo
les deux roues c'est quelque chose qui
est complètement nouveau et je pense
qu'il ya encore beaucoup de choses à
faire et tendre sur ce sport là ce
samedi 4 juin le célèbre youtuber
football devine sky aux centaines de
millions de vues sur internet avait
également fait le déplacement
une opportunité pour lui de faire
découvrir sa pratique il a également
rencontré ses abonnés
franchement c'est une réussite il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont venus est bon
il faisait beau il a commencé à pleuvoir
pendant que je fais à l'interview mais
alors franchement c'est top il ya du
petit pont il ya du une sujet entre ya
un peu de tout y est même du vélo du bmx
donc franchement c'est une grande
réussite pour mais en tout cas j'ai
vraiment apprécié avec près de 2000
visiteurs cette fête de la jeunesse est
considérée comme un succès une nouvelle
édition est prévue l'année prochaine
[Musique]
suite au premier tour des élections
législatives douze candidats de la
majorité présidentielle seront opposés à
onze candidats de la nuque baisse et un
candidat du rassemblement national dans
les circonscriptions du département des
yvelines pour le second tour nous vous
proposons sur télé 78 une série de
débats avec les deux candidats qualifiés
dans différentes circonscriptions du
territoire parmi eux les douze futur
député des yvelines les candidats
défendront leurs propositions sur le
pouvoir d'achat l'environnement ou
encore les enjeux de leur
circonscription
rendez vous mercredi 15 juin à 18h sur
tv 78 des émissions que vous pouvez
retrouver en replay sur notre chaîne
youtube
[Musique]
je m'appelle manon moynier chevrières
sur la commune de saint nom la bretèche
j'ai rejoint l'exploitation familiale
depuis deux ans
oh
donc j'ai 40 chèvres adultes ici avec un
petit j'ai deux races de chèvre du coup
les chèvres blanches céder sa laine et
les marrons cd alpine ou de race
différente une qui fait du lait plus
gras et une qui fait plus de là
alors moi je n'étais pas du tout dans le
métier j'ai une famille d'agriculteurs m
agriculteurs depuis quatre générations à
famille moi je suis issu du
médico-social j'étais l'éducatrice je
m'occupais de personnes autistes et puis
j'ai arrêté du coup pour venir m'occuper
des chèvres qu'il n'y avait pas ici de
chèvres mais je devais un jour reprendre
l'exploitation familiale donc j'ai
cherché à quelque chose qui me plairait
et j'ai fait un stage à l'échelle ça m'a
vraiment plu puisque c'est des animaux
très proche de l'homme
j'ai fait un bac pro à distance pendant
mon travail d'éducatrice pour pas
arrêter de travailler et puis j'ai
arrêté de travailler le jour où les
chèvres sont arrivés sur l'exploitation
donc en septembre 2020
du coup là c'est la future chèvrerie qui
sera fini d'être construite on espère
avant l'été où on pourrait accueillir du
coup les 200 chefs parce qu'à terme je
vais accueillir 200 chèvres voilà avec à
gauche les modules blanc c'est l'atelier
de transformation en glace et en fromage
et la future boutique sur le même site
comme on accueille aussi beaucoup de
gens il ya une ferme pédagogique qui est
en train de se construire sur le terrain
pour l'accueil de groupes en situation
de handicap mais aussi de public en
général
[Musique]
avec l'aide des chefs je transforme en
glace exclusivement effet bientôt en
fromage
ça c'est la machine de glace
qui passe terisse de l'est et qu'ils ont
mais le mélange de dans une fois que
c'est fait ça descend ça turbine grâce à
l'air ça donne une texture de glace ça
sort un peu comme une glace à
l'italienne et ensuite on le moule soual
en dépôt dans des petits pots soit on
peut en faire comme la des eskimos
[Musique]
la glace sur les chefs n'a pas debout
disney que lé moins grasse on retrouvera
pas l'odeur du fromage de chèvre par
exemple
là on a de la glace à la noisette donc
c'est moi qui fais moi même ma purée
noisette là il ya de la glace au miel
c'est du miel local de crespières des
deux gourmands de la biscuiterie
miellerie les deux gourmands
[Musique]
c'est très important de discuter avec
les gens de leur présenter ce qu'est
l'élevage comme on s'occupe de nos
animaux les difficultés qu'on peut
rencontrer ou les moments de bonheur
qu'on croise j'aime partager avec les
gens donc je veux que ça reste important
et je veux je veux créer un emploi
protégé aussi c'est quelque chose de
très important qui me avec mon ancien
métier aussi
[Musique]